[Music]
all right good morning my name is
Sandeep today I want to talk to you
about micro services with kubernetes and
sto so I'm a developer advocate on the
Google cloud I've been working with
kubernetes for the past three years it's
grown a lot and it's do is the next new
hot thing coming out so you're all here
to learn about it so let's go because we
all know microservices are awesome right
when you have a traditional application
like a monolith you'd have all of your
logic in one app right so a java app
ruby app node whatever you would have
all the code in your one app it would do
all the parts maybe using like object
orientation so you have different
classes I'd need different things but at
the end of the day you know it's like
one big program that does all the stuff
there's a lot of advantages to doing
this monolithic type of development it's
easier to debug it's easier to deploy
you just have one thing you just push it
out and you're done
and when you have a really small team
and you have a very small app it's
really easy to do but the problem with
the monolith comes when your app starts
to grow a little bigger so now you have
all of these things and all these
different pieces but you still have one
app that's doing all of it right so
anytime you want to make a change in
invoicing that means you how to redeploy
the whole thing even though the ETL
pipeline might have not been affected at
all and maybe the invoicing part is
really good to be done in Java the ETL
pipeline you want to use Python and the
front-end you want to use nodejs but if
you have a monolithic app can't really
do that you're kind of stuck into using
one language so a team that wants to
make an update to one little part has to
touch the whole thing and things start
to get really hairy really quickly so
with microservices each one of these
becomes its own individual component
that can be written in its own language
that can be updated and deployed
independently of the others and so this
gives you a lot more agility a lot more
flexibility a lot more speed and a lot
more cool things like that and so you're
like yeah this one's really good why is
anyone using monoliths
because once you start going even bigger
it gets even more complicated right
honestly a monolith would fall apart at
this point too but even all the
advantages of the micro service start to
get really hard to manage because now
not you don't have this 20 micro
services you have 2,000 micro services
right and how do you know which one
talks to which one and how the intricate
spider web of connections even works you
might have a single request that comes
in to your load balancer like it's sent
to like 20 thousand different micro
services and then all the way back up
and anywhere that chain breaks your
whole application looks like it's broken
right and so debugging this becomes
super hard deploying things making sure
everything is in lockstep with each
other it becomes really difficult to try
to manage this huge stack of services so
our micro service is terrible maybe but
we can use a lot of tooling to try to
make them more manageable right so let's
use tools to kind of automate this
infrastructure components automate the
networking components automate the
management side of things and so when
you look at a monolith versus a micro
service they both have a lot of
complexity the difference is and unless
you know something that I don't there's
no tools out there that automatically
write code for you and can maintain a
two million line Java app right it's
like some magic AI that can write code
we'll all be out of jobs maybe in a few
years but now we do have tools like
kubernetes like docker like Sto
like Google Cloud that can automate
infrastructure a lot more easily right
so a lot of the issues that we have with
micro service can be automated away so
let's take a look at some of those tools
so how many people are familiar with
docker I expect a lot of hands to go up
yep so for those of you are not familiar
with docker docker is basically a way to
package your application so it doesn't
matter if you're writing node code
Python Java whatever doesn't matter if
you have image magic some random library
that's some thirteen-year-old kid and
your crane compiled it doesn't matter
you put it in your docker container and
you're good to go all you have to do is
care about running the container you
know how to big you don't have to care
about running what's inside of it
right
so basically take your code in your
dependencies and you put it into some
sort of generic container format and so
it doesn't matter what's inside as long
as you can run a container you can run
all the containers so now you have a
container you got to actually run it on
your cluster right because logging into
a single machine and then running docker
run and then doing that thousand times
seems like a waste of time to me
so instead we can use something like
kubernetes which is a container
orchestration system and what we can do
with that is we can say hey kubernetes
run this container like five times
somewhere in my cluster and so what
it'll do is it'll run your containers
for you automatically right and so let's
say you want to run this container that
container that container and that
container and you want two copies of
each you just tell kubernetes that and
it figures out how to run them and so
the really nice thing about this is if a
server crashes it'll figure out that
that server crash and run them somewhere
else if the application crashes it'll
figure that out if you want to scale it
up right you want to go from two copies
to four copies you can say hey make it
four and it'll spin up two more you want
to go down to one because you're like
want to save some money you can say hey
make one it will remove three right and
so this like a declarative syntax that
makes it really easy to manage these
containers running on your cluster right
you might have thousands of these
running trying to do it manually is
going to be impossible and how many
people have heard of kubernetes and keep
your hands up if you've used it before
okay cool
but that's kind of just a starting point
right now you have these containers
running you have to have to manage the
services because you have container a
talking-to container be talking to
container so you talking to container D
how do you manage that set of points
going between each other how do you set
rules on who can talk to who who can
talk to what how many tries should you
have how much network traffic should you
send all the test stuff becomes really
complicated and that's where sto comes
into play so SDO is a service mesh which
at the end of the day it means that it
manages your services and the
connections that they make between
themselves right so if you look at it we
take orchestration and we go to
management and communication so you want
to manage how these services interact
with each other because that's what
really causes microservices to be so
useful is the communication between each
other you can reuse one service you can
talk to three different ones give it the
same information you can mix and match
and do all these really powerful things
but it becomes hard to really understand
what's happening and it still makes it a
lot easier to understand what's
happening and control what's happening
all right so that's enough of me just
talking about random things let's
actually move to a demo and if we can go
to the screen thank you very much okay
and I can't see anything sweet so what
we're gonna do first actually can go
back to the slides real quick I didn't
tell you what we're gonna do
so what we're gonna do is a walk through
the end-to-end story of picking an app
and making it into a micro service so
we're gonna take a nap put it into a
container run that container locally
store the container on the cloud then
we're going to create a kubernetes
cluster run our app on that cluster then
scale it out and then we're going to do
something a little bit more interesting
we're going to run multiple apps up work
together a true micro services pattern
and then we're going to monitor and
manage them with hto awesome so let's
move back to the demo cool so here I'm
using Google Cloud shell if you haven't
used it before it's basically a free VM
in the cloud that lets you do your
development work I'm on a Chromebook
right now running the dev build if it
all crashes we're going to do like
jumping jacks until it comes back or
something I don't know it happens before
so basically here I have some code it's
a little node.js application if you
don't know JavaScript that's fine
it's a really simple app basically it's
a web server that listens to slash and
it will basically ping a downstream so
in this case it'll ping time Jason test
comm and then it'll concatenate that
response and then send it to us so let's
run this locally right now
nope nope doesn't want node modules okay
the Internet
okay so if I go npm start see what
happens cool so it's listening on port
3000 so I will that's fine I'll do this
let's go to port 3000 on cloud shell we
can do a web preview so it looks like we
were basically running a local machine
awesome so you can see here that we go
to time vegetation test comm and we
print out our current service name which
is test one version one and we're seeing
the current time so if i refresh this
you know the time will change right
awesome cool so now let's take this and
put it into a docker container so to
make a docker container basically what
we do is we make something called a
docker file so a docker file is
basically a set of instructions that
creates this like endpoint so you can
almost think of it like a bash script
it's basically what it is so here we
start with notate alpine so that's kind
of a base image it gives us a bunch of
the node stuff out of the box so we
don't have to worry about installing
nodejs then we copy in our package JSON
which has her dependencies run npm
install to install those dependencies
copy in our index j ass which is our
code expose some ports and then run NPM
start so once we run docker build it'll
create a docker container
so let's actually build and run that
container just for a sake of time I've
already built it so
local so here when I run that container
once I built it okay
Oh nope I need to build it cool so I
should just build it it's just not found
so this might take a little bit of time
and well Lord while we're building this
let's switch to going and building our
kubernetes cluster so here in our
kubernetes if i go to the google
kubernetes engine google kubernetes
engine is Google's manage kubernetes
offering right and so it's probably the
easiest way to create a production-ready
kubernetes cluster so what you can do is
just click create cluster and you get a
bunch of options on what you can do to
create this cluster so here you can get
a name in your description you can make
it a zonal or a regional cluster and
this is a really cool feature where you
can have multiple masters so it's highly
available so even if a loan goes down
your cluster will still be up and
running you can choose the version of
Cooper Nettie's you want the size of the
cluster and then a bunch of not- 21
let's not do that you can do a lot of
other cool features to that google
kubernetes engine gives you
out-of-the-box
things like no automatically upgrading
your nodes automatically repairing them
as to get broken
logging monitoring and a lot more - for
example auto scaling you can turn auto
scaling on which means that if you have
more cluster if you have more containers
that can fit in your cluster google
kubernetes engine will actually
automatically scale it up to create that
space and even better if you have less
containers will actually scale it down
to save you money which is really cool
so cool a lot of that cool stuff and
then all you have to do is click create
and it'll create that cluster so I'm
flip cancel clay already did one it's
like a cooking show we have one ready in
the oven this is still going
that's okay
what we'll do instead so I've already
built this and I've pushed it so we're
going to do the opposite of what I said
and we're going to pull it down
speaks so icon cheated but that's okay
so let's run that container locally okay
so we're going to do with docker is
we're gonna say docker run and then
we're going to open up that port 3000
and so if you look if we go back here
you can see that it's basically the
exact same thing except now it's running
in docker and so the really nice thing
is we don't have to change any four code
we just put it into a docker container
and we're good to go right okay cool so
the next step is actually pushing it to
a container registry and the reason why
we have to do this is because we can't
just run containers running on our local
machine we're gonna push them to a
secure location so we can run them on
our cluster and Google container
registry is probably the best place to
put them if you're running google
kubernetes engine right you get
automatic authentication and stuff and a
few other features we'll look at in a
second so let's actually push it up
that's not how you spell make and I love
using make makes demo super easy so what
we're gonna do is run docker push and
can people read that or should I make a
little bigger alright people can read it
so docker push and then give the name of
the container so what will happen is
it'll actually go to Google container
registry and so here in my sto test
container you can see that we have the
newest ones pushed up right now and it's
tag that's version 1.0 now if I enabled
it one really cool thing that they could
do is vulnerability scanning so we can
actually scan your containers for known
vulnerabilities automatically for any
bunty or Alpine based images so that's a
really cool thing especially if you have
older containers if you have them
updated in a while you go back and look
and you'll have tons of vulnerabilities
so it's a really good idea to like check
this out it's in the beta right now but
it'll find a bunch of stuff wrong with
your things and tell you how to fix them
and then you just go update your usually
just update your containers and you're
good to go so it's a really good thing
especially running on production
and running older
containers so now we have this pushed up
we actually can start to deploy to a
kubernetes cluster so like I said before
we already have a cluster created let's
go back there now basically to connect
to it we just run this command all right
let's run it
great so now we can say cube CTL which
is a kubernetes command line tool get
nodes just to make sure everything is
working
is everything working that's a good
question yep there it is
so we have a four node kubernetes
cluster they're all good to go
we're running version 1.9 that's seven
so here now we have our kubernetes
cluster and we're authenticated to it we
can start running the same container
that we ran locally so what we're going
to do is do cube CTL run demo and then
give it the name of that image and demo
is going to be the name of the
deployment that we're going to create so
if I say a cube CTL get deploy mint and
then give that namespace the namespaces
just for this demo sake don't worry
about it you don't need to in real life
so you can see that we have our demo
deployment created and if you say get
pods
and so pods are basically the containers
and kubernetes you can see that we have
our container created it's ready and
it's running but now that it's running
you have to be able to actually access
it right and so this is where it gets a
little bit more complicated we're in the
old world with a docker you just kind of
access it directly because this is
running on your local machine but in the
kubernetes world it's running on one of
those four nodes and we really don't
care which one so we want a static
endpoint that can route traffic and
access that that node right so what
we're gonna do is create a service and
now I forget what my make command is
that's okay let's go look it's like a
cheat sheet let's see
expose there it is cool so what we'll do
here is we'll run cube CTL expose and
then we'll give it the target port of
3000 which is where our no genius app is
listening and then run it on port 80 so
accessible HTTP port and we'll open a
type load balancer which will give us a
public IP address using a Google cloud I
load bouncer so now we can say get
service
and that's you most people here are
familiar with kubernetes if you're not
familiar coming to talk to me i know i'm
going kind of quickly but there's more
exciting things to to happen soon so we
want to get to them so you can see the
external IP address is pending solicit
run a watch on that and it's done the
moment i try anything complicated it
just finishes it knows all right cool
let's go to that URL dad not copy it all
right all right all right all right all
right let's do this cool and if you go
here you can see the exact same app
running on our cluster so now we
actually have it running on a public IP
address if you go there on your phone or
laptop it'll work and what we can do
let's say all you go on on your phone to
this IP address will probably overwhelm
you know this app so in kubernetes we
can actually just scale it out with the
scale command so let's do that so let's
say cube CTL scale deployment demo the
name of the deployment I'm gonna say
replicas equals 5 and again that
namespace
awesome so it'll say deployment demo
scaled so now if we go back to our get
pods you'll notice that we actually have
five of them running in our cluster
which is really cool so and then if you
say get deployments you can see it also
says that we have five desired five
current five up-to-date and five
available so now if we go back to the IP
address it still works the only
difference is it's now round-robin and
traffic between all five instances of
our application right so we have a lot
more scalability a lot more robustness
and you might notice that we're running
five copies even though we only have
four VMs right that's because we're able
to run multiple copies on single VM so
we get more utilization out of our
machines okay all right so let's clean
that up we no longer need that demo
let's start looking at Sto so now we had
a single service running kind of useless
in in the long scheme of things right no
one just runs one thing you don't need
kubernetes to do that what you really
want to do is run multiple applications
together and make sure they all work
together well so what we're going to do
is what we're going to do is run this
same application three times and then
chain it together so you might have
noticed in our code I'm gonna go back to
it for a second that basically I can set
whatever I want as the upstream URI
using an environment variable and so
what I can do is actually tie multiple
of these together using one to talk to
the other to talk to the other and then
finally the time that JSON test comm and
then they're all they will all
concatenate the responses and finally
like show it to the end end user so
that's a really cool thing I can in
kubernetes we can actually dynamically
set these environment variables when
we're deploying so let's actually look
at that and so normally in kubernetes
what we would do is we'd create a yam
well file I'm gonna make this a little
bigger and in this yellow file we will
define our deployments so I'm gonna make
four deployments
so the first one can become fall called
front-end prod so front-end production
service did you can see here I'm gonna
get the service name front and prod and
the upstream URI I'm going to call it
middleware and so kubernetes will
automatically do dns based service
discovery so I can actually find my
middleware application by just pointing
it at middleware this was really cool
I don't need IP addresses or anything
like that and you can see here we're
giving it some labels app front end
version prod and then the same container
name that we used before and then in our
middleware everything looks exactly the
same except it's app middleware a
version prod and then the service name
is different and the upstream URI is now
back in and we also have a canary
version of our middleware so it's like a
test version that we're just kind of
working on but we want to see how it
works in the real world so again this
also points to back in and then finally
our back-end which points to time Jason
test.com okay so at this point we can
deploy it into our cluster
and so now we'll create these
deployments but of course we also need
to create the corresponding services so
they can actually find each other so
let's take a look at that so here in our
services yeah mol it's pretty
straightforward we have a front-end a
middleware and a back-end service they
all open up port 3000 to port 80 which
makes sense the only difference here is
the front end service is a pipe load
balancer so that we get that public IP
address cool so let's go to that public
IP address and see what happens
great okay still pending that's fine
let's do one more time there we go
okay so interesting it was a little bit
different than before you can see that
our front-end prod went to our
middleware
then the middleware went to our back-end
and our back in winter time that Jason
tests calm but we're getting a 404 which
is really weird because you know I mean
if I go to this website clearly it works
we're seeing it working all this time
before right it's working so why are we
getting a 404 and so now we go into the
world of Sto
so I've actually have sto already
running in this cluster and what its
gonna do is it's gonna really lock down
and help you manage your micro services
so it knows that time Jason test com is
an external service and by default it's
gonna block all traffic going out of
your cluster and this is really good for
security reasons you don't want your app
just talking to a random endpoints on
the internet right you want you as a
cluster administrator to be able to lock
down and only talk to trusted endpoints
so by default everything is blocked
that's going out of your cluster so how
do you unblock it well an sto
we have something called egress rules so
it's a pretty simple thing you can see
it's only like a few lines of gamal and
so here we're gonna say allow traffic to
time that jason test comm on both port
84 HTTP and 443 for HTTPS so let's
deploy that rule
cool
and for is do we use the HDL control
command-line tool it's just like the
cube control or cube CTL issue CTL I
don't know how to pronounce it your
guess is as good as mine
but it's very similar to the cube
control tool and so now we've created
that we can go back to our website and
hit refresh and you can see it's all
working perfectly fine so you kind of
whitelisted traffic to time died chasing
task.com
now you might notice another thing going
on if I hit refresh just look at this
line right here sometimes it says canary
and sometimes it says prod right and so
the reason why this is happening is by
default kubernetes will use round blob
and load balancing for its services
right so our middleware service is
pointing to any deployment or any pod
that has to tag app middleware but both
the canary and the prod versions both
have that tag so kubernetes will blindly
send traffic to both in fact if you had
three versions of canary and only two
versions of your prod a disproportionate
mono traffic would go to Canaria in fact
three to two right because it's just
round-robin a so with this do we can
actually make traffic go exactly where
we want let's do that real fast
okay so what we can do is set something
called a route role and basically we can
send whenever the destination is
middleware you know always send it to
prot and then whenever a destination is
front-ends and defraud and backends and
prod right super simple things but what
this happens is now hit refresh it'll
always go to our production service so
as an end user I never have to worry
about it I'll always hit production I
won't hit some like random test build
that's running in my cluster which is
really nice okay but this is great this
app is like bulletproof right it's so
simple it never breaks but in the real
world we have our code is not you know
perfect I don't write perfect code you
don't write perfect code let's be honest
with each other in the real world things
break all the time so to simulate that I
have this really cool function called
create issues and what create issues
will do is it'll look at a header called
fail and then if that it will generally
generate a number and if it's less than
that it'll just return a 500 yeah I
didn't know how else to make things
break on purpose it's hard to make
things break on purpose so if you've got
a program called postman and if you've
never used it before it's awesome
basically lets you set like headers and
json and things like that automatically
so let's just do a normal request right
now you can see it works just the same
way as doing the request from the web
browser but now we can actually send
headers from the this tool and let's set
a value of 0.3 so it's a 30% chance of
failure let's see what happens boom back
and failed boom middleware failed
everything worked back and failed again
everything worked again middleware
failed there everything failed right and
you might notice that the problem is
actually worse than we think because in
our code what we're actually doing is
we're propagating these headers these
are for tracing we'll take a look at
that in a second but we're actually
forwarding this fail header along each
request right so it's not just a 30%
chance it's a 30% times 34
sometimes 30% chance of failure right
and that's where all this cascading
failures come to play with microservices
because one failure can just trigger
tons of failures downstream so let's
take a look how sto can help us with
this so let's do our second routing
rules let's do something called a simple
retry policy so let's have sto
automatically retry the request three
times before giving up and again we
don't have to change our code at all
right SDL is transparently proxying all
of these Network calls proxying is a
strong word transparently managing all
these Network calls so what happens is
our code doesn't have to know at all
that sto is trying is three times it
just tries it once
and sto actually manages all the back
off and the retries and all that kind of
stuff for you automatically so you don't
have to so now if we go back to postman
let's see what happens
boom working working working it was
still some issues working working
working working much better obviously it
didn't fix the issue in fact if I
increase this to something like versions
0.5 you can see you know it's gonna fail
a lot more or not you know it might not
feel it might mask that okay you know
what
0.9 all right see failure and you might
notice it's failing a lot at the front
too right so let's take a look at two
things one it's able to mask masks your
mask mas que your failures but you don't
want it to always do that right just
because things are working this I mean
things are good you want to be able to
detect that you have errors and be able
to detect that and fix it so sto
actually gives you a lot of tooling
out-of-the-box to manage your your
systems so the first thing I want to
show you is something called service
graph so because sto sitting and
intercepting all those Network calls is
actually able to create a full picture
of your services for you so you can see
here we have a front-end talking to
or prod and canary talking to our
back-end just talking the time that
Jason test comm we can also start doing
things automatically start getting
metrics from our cluster as well wow
that looks way too zoomed in alright so
you went a little bit you can see here
once we started adding those others
errors our global success rate just
started crashing to the bottom right and
so SDO will actually automatically find
your 500 soar 400s your volume your QPS
your latency all the stuff automatically
for you and start throwing it onto
Prometheus and other dashboards so you
can start putting them into your systems
and start running metrics and
understanding what is going on in your
services right and I go ahead to write
any code for this it still gives me all
these metrics out of the box for free
and then finally we can use something
like Zipkin or Jager to do tracing so
our stackdriver trace a lot of these
tools all work so let's find some traces
so you can see here we can see our front
end talks our middleware talks to our
back-end and we can see that obviously
the backend takes the longest amount of
time because it's talking to our
external service right but even more
interesting than this
you can see here it actually has back in
2x front and 2x and middle bear 2x yeah
I can't find one
that's okay let's see look back one our
traces that's okay so you can you can
see all the distributed tracing and to
do that all I had to do was forward
those trace headers along let's look
that for a one second those trace
headers so as long as I'm forwarding
those trace headers I get distributed
tracing for free out of the box and
actually have another talk where I talk
about open census which can
automatically forward these for you as
well so even less work for you as a
developer okay now let's do one final
thing so here you can see when I hit
refresh I'm always going to my prod
service but as a tester I kind of want
to actually use a canary service and see
what happens in this new path right and
the really nice thing is we can do in
production testing using this do because
when we have a thousands of services
it's impossible to launch them all in
our local machine and test it that way
right we want to kind of push our
service like our you know you think it's
working and so you push it into our
production cluster but we don't want any
production traffic hitting it we just
want to test traffic hitting it so we're
going to do is put up the last and final
route rule and it's going to make a new
route called a middleware canary route
and what it's going to look for is a
header called X dev user and then
whenever it sees the value of super
secret it's going to route it to our
canary so all normal traffic will go to
a production service and then the
super-secret traffic will go to our
canary service obviously you'd use
something like Olaf or some sort of
authentication scheme not just the word
super-secret because you know security
is important so let's take a look at
that
so make canary
so let's deploy this rule and so now if
it go here obviously it'll still go to
our production service but if we got a
postman and let's remove that fail
header and let's go to X dev user super
boom nope can I spell it wrong I don't
know let's see what happened what
happens
oh just disabled aha there we go thank
you all right there we go middle of our
canary right so we're able to route to a
specific service in the middle of our
stack using headers and that's because
we're using header propagation so even
if you had like 20,000 mm services and
you want to make the middle one the
900th service a special thing by
propagating these headers we can
actually use sto and then route to that
one even if it's in the middle of our
stack right so now it's just a front end
we can test anything in the whole stack
using this do and header propagation Oh
all right let's switch back to the
slides please okay so we do all this
stuff thank you all so much if you want
to get a deeper dive into sto it's
basically this top with a little bit
more things focus specifically on this
do you can check out my main com /s do
one on one it'll have a youtube video
all this code is open source on my
github again if you go to that website
sto 101 I have a link to my github
repository there you can check out
Google kubernetes engine at gos you can
e st o io follow me on twitter if you
have any questions please follow me out
the door I'm going to go staffs the
office hours right now so come talk to
me there or talk to me right outside or
find me in the sandbox I'm happy to
answer any questions I know we went kind
of quickly today but yeah thank you all
so much enjoy the rest of your i/o enjoy
the concert tonight and I'll see you out
there
[Applause]
[Music]